welcome to rag the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study it's nice to see you
wonderful turnout for the deans lecture
here so so perhaps remind you or tell
you the Radcliffe Institute is primarily
a multiple multi disciplinary Institute
that knits together the arts humanities
sciences and social sciences we have a
fellowship program we have a program on
science symposia there's a gender
conference coming up one gender and
violence on April 9th and 10th my name
is John Heath so let me introduce our
speaker for today David Montgomery he is
a professor at the university of
washington heads a geomorphology group
is also a MacArthur Fellow the author of
three books and another book that is
forthcoming and we've had I have know
somewhat similar interests in kind of
the the way science develops and a not
so straight and narrow path as sometimes
we're taught and so this appeals to me
greatly
so geomorphology for those of you who
don't know is is the study of how the
topography of earth's surface is
influenced by events like earthquakes
and floods and in fact the issue of the
flood and the Noah story is a topic of
today's story
I should mention on a personal note I
always like to throw on a personal note
is a few years back I was doing a
backpacking trip in eastern Washington
State and as I was driving to do this
backpacking trip we were traveling
through the strange landscape and I had
no idea what on earth was happening with
this landscape because it look weird
something I'd never seen before and I
was just scratching my head as to what
on earth might have created this so
about a year and a half ago I read his
book
the rocks don't lie and in it he has a
piece in the chapter about the so called
scablands in Eastern Washington where of
this Lake about 15,000 years ago Lake
masuleh burst forth and and flooded that
part of Eastern Washington and created
the landscape and all of a sudden I
realized that what I was seeing was the
result of this giant flood and it's so
all the stuff that I didn't know how to
interpret came together in one flash of
insight and I thought that was just
absolutely marvelous so I was delighted
with his book and this was one of the
motivations for inviting him here
because it's cross-disciplinary and it's
fascinating topic so without any further
ado David welcome to hear you talk about
faith in nature
I'm a geologist by training has you've
just heard and one of the things that
I've been asked about by this book you
may be wondering is why would a
professional geologist in the 21st
century write a book about Noah's Flood
I hope that about 40 minutes from now
you'll sort of see the path that I took
in sort of coming to write a book about
Noah's Flood and share the sort of the
interest in the excitement and the
thinking of the history and development
of the science of geology something that
I wasn't really formally taught in any
detail other than what I now knows as a
cartoon version but also as I started
looking into the history of thought in
Christianity the way theology looked at
the idea and thought about the flood and
the way that this sort of tension
between faith and reason has been
portrayed in a lot of histories was
actually a lot more complicated and
interactive and cross pollinating than I
ever really knew about so I invite you
to sort of share with me the story of
how I sort of went through writing this
book the rocks don't lie and where it
really started was in southeastern Tibet
I had no sort of knowledge that I was
going to be sort of researching and
looking at the effect of really big
floods and the origin of flood stories
until I got asked to join a scientific
expedition to the southeastern Tibet to
the gorge at that Tsangpo River I was
that the token geomorphologist they need
they need a river person on this project
and I was the guy that sort of knew some
of the people involved they asked me if
I wanted to go on this expedition to
Tibet I was like sure volunteer no
problem but what do I need to do what am
i studying and as it so often turns out
the thing that we actually proposed to
do in zhu morphology was not the thing
that i got really excited about after i
got there and saw the landscape and
started reading pieces of it like this
piece that you see behind me this is a
topographic terrace it's a lake terrace
in the valley of the tanco river
upstream of the gorge where the river
flows down through the himalaya cars one
of the deepest canyons on earth and then
flows out to become the Brahmaputra
where it gets down into India this is in
the eastern corner of the Himalaya where
the Tibetan border hits India and
remember my Anwar whatever you want to
call it and this Valley is a very
interesting place these very prominent
features are essentially tell me as a
geologist that there had been standing
water in this lake it's a for the
geologist in the audience it's a Gilbert
type Delta there's four sets and top set
beds but basically the non geologists
there was a lake that it reached at
least up to about that level at some
point in the geological past and we
found sort of example after example of
these terrorists is going downstream
through this valley that I had not
really thought were there when we
proposed to go study it and I started
realizing it hey there was a really big
lake that had been in this valley
sometime in the geological past we
started collecting samples out of these
terraces to try and ascertain their
their age and there was one really big
problem though as we were driving down
stream following the course this river
mapping terrace after Terrace you could
project the water level from these lakes
right out through the gorge of the tanco
River there in other words there was
nothing to hold the water in and so we
started puzzling over well what was the
dam what actually created these lakes in
the first place and when we got down to
just near the head of the gorge of the
tangka River
we found our candidate which is
essentially these glacial moraines these
piles of Earth that were bulldozed by a
glacier that came off the high peak of
namja baro up here as ice at some time
in the past bulldoze these these giant
moraine ZUP and notice it's truncated
here these Marines had extended all the
way across the valley you can find
scraps of this glacial debris on the far
side of the valley it dammed the river
what happens when you dam a river well
you get a lake behind it but what
happens when you dam a river with a wall
of ice that's not exactly the best thing
in the world to make a dam out a visit
and what happens is essentially when you
float the dam you release the lake it's
a recipe for causing a really big flood
and the truncated nature of these
moraine sort of or the occurrence of
these big floods in the past and I got
really excited because this is not what
I'd gone to Tibet to try and work on and
see in the process of science when you
discover something unexpected you know
that really is where a lot of the joy of
doing science comes into it and so I got
really excited was really thrilled about
this and I started to then talk to some
of the local Tibetan villagers about how
thrilled I was to have discover
and that their Valley had been filled
with a lake at some time in the past and
that a really big flood had drained the
lake and essentially created the
landscape the topography the
geomorphology that we could see today
and like this sort of story was
translated from English to Chinese to
Tibetan back to Chinese back to English
and the reply that I got really kind of
shocked me because it was basically
something like oh yeah I know about that
there were three boats stranded up there
on the side of the valley when the lake
drained am sitting there thinking you
know I just discovered this thing how
could you know about it and it basically
there was an oral tradition of this lake
draining in or a lake draining in this
valley that I was unaware of at the time
or before this trip and I was even more
surprised when we got our carbon dates
back from some of the lake sediments and
they dated out at about the eighth
century AD about twelve hundred years
ago I think that's the late Tang Dynasty
if I'm remembering that such things
correctly and it turns out that there's
this story of this gentleman shown on
the screen behind me
Padma Sun bhava guru Rinpoche the second
tantric the second historical Buddha the
tantric Buddha the guy who introduced
Buddhism into Tibet through the valley
of the saenko River by doing things like
yes draining the lake by fighting the
demon of the lake and essentially
draining it to reveal the fertile
farmland the people still farm today so
in other words I had come to and I not
done the geological field work ahead of
time to put the story of this lake
together and if I had heard that story I
would have considered it a folk tale a
folk story something that you know maybe
they saw these kind of features I was
seeing it was made a story that to try
and explain the topography but this made
me start to wonder whether or not there
was AG real geological basis to the
story of many of the world's flood
stories because it seemed like there's
at least a very plausible case to be
made for this one in Tibet having its
roots in an actual event that may have
occurred some 1200 years ago well this
got me into thinking about things like
you know the world's other flood stories
as you might imagine it would and I
started to look at things like the
global distribution of flood stories and
you know many people have done this in
the past but if you kind of look at it
and parse the geography and the details
in some of those stories you actually
can put together some fairly interesting
observations but the other flood stories
are from the surround the Pacific Rim
sort of in this area
region there across North America
mulaskey across the Midwest up into
Scandinavia and of course there's a few
very famous flood stories or one in
particular out of the Middle East what
about that distribution well it turned
to that in a minute but what first about
the characteristics of flood stories a
lot has been made about the parallels
between flood stories in different parts
of the world and the most common
elements among the world's flood stories
are really that people survived
destruction by water through some type
of Bogor arc and many of the other
details actually vary a lot between
different regions but those key elements
essentially that there was some means of
escape that the flood was caused by
water that's kind of a note that that's
a gimme right and that somebody was safe
to tell the story those are the three
elements that you would have to have in
terms of any flood story in order for
the story to have been occurred been
recorded and been essentially
transmitted I got really interested then
in the differences between flood stories
not the commonalities they are
distributed around many parts of the
world not everywhere but the other
question need to wrestle with in terms
of thinking about whether or not a oral
traditions like this actually could
relate to real events is how long could
you actually expect an oral tradition to
survive transmission and still
faithfully repeal it a story the best
example I can find one that seems to be
pretty clear is the Klamath Indian story
recorded in 1865 that reads an awful lot
like an eyewitness account of the
eruption of Mount Mazama the one that
formed Crater Lake about seventy seven
hundred years ago if you read that and
sort of filter it through the
differences in culture and and state of
scientific knowledge between the Native
American community and the Klamath
region some 8,000 years ago and today
you can you can basically read it as
almost an eyewitness description of the
eruption and if that's right
it suggests that oral traditions could
at least have been transmitted down
through on the order seven eight
thousand years that number will come
back a little later in the talk but it
basically suggests that there may be
something to the idea that these that
stories of real of geological events
could survive transmission to become
some of the world's oldest stories now
if you look at some of those details of
different flood stories around the world
and parse them a little bit there's sort
of two areas that I'll go into the first
at tsunami stories there's an awful lot
of the world's flood stories that do not
involve rainfall and
this greatly mystified Christian
missionaries to the South Pacific when
they ran into stories in Tahiti and Fiji
where the natives knew all about the
flood but it didn't come from the sky it
came from the sea and it came
unexpectedly and they kept canoes at the
ready in case it would come back again
someday
stories that read a lot like tsunamis
have been recorded in Alaska South
America the Pacific Northwest that the
Pacific Islands as I mentioned Southeast
Asia and one in particular that I'm fond
of is the native story from the coast of
Chile that tells how two great serpents
bide to see who could make the sea rise
more causing an earthquake and sending a
great wave onto the shore and those
parts of the world where you have what
are known to geologist has subduction
zones where you have one tectonic plate
being shoved underneath the other where
you get great earthquakes like I hope
doesn't happen in Seattle anytime soon
basically can generate fairly large
tsunamis that if you read a lot of these
native stories in these areas they sound
an awful lot like eyewitness description
of tsunamis similarly if you look
towards the northern margins of the
great Pleistocene ice sheets the sheets
of ice that occupied the poles during
the last major glacial periods there's
stories in Scandinavia the one I told
you about in Tibet some in Alaska
stemmed from Oregon and Washington the
Great Lakes region the Mississippi
Valley that read like essentially dam
break floods I they're probably related
to events in those areas the one I'm
particularly fond of is one captured in
that that cartoon cover there that shows
how Odin and his brothers killed you mer
the ice giant and causing his blood
which of course would be water from an
ice giant to gush forth in a great flood
which drowned a whole lot of animals and
it's sort of central to Nordic Nordic
mythology there's similar kinds of
stories from Native American communities
but the geography is essentially
circumpolar in the northern hemisphere
for the ones that involve ice now I'm
not the first person by any stretch of
the imagination to wrestle with the sort
of the geography of flood stories
worldwide a lot of people have done so
and about a century ago a guy named
James Fraser wrote a book called
folklore in the Old Testament where he
actually compiled a list of many of the
world's flood stories and then went
through them and sort of thought about
what they might represent and tried to
parse them into which ones were myths
which ones were legends and his
conclusion is worth reading I think in
full because it's
hundred years old and it's very good and
he actually came to very similar
conclusion to what I came to based on
frankly less work
he wrote that there seems to be a good
good reason for thinking that some and
probably many diluting traditions are
merely exaggerated reports of floods
which actually occurred weather is the
result of heavy rain earthquake waves or
other causes all such traditions
therefore partly legendary and partly
mythical so far as they preserve
reminiscences of floods which really
happened they are legendary and so far
as they describe Universal Day losses
which never happened they are mythical
he was essentially arguing along the
lines that I was a moment ago that you
could sort of look back at real events
underpinning some of these and that's
some of the stories may be somewhat
elaborated and to be to be fair there
are some of the world's flood stories
that I can't make any sense out of at
all but I won't be talking much about
them today so what about the historical
basis for the Biblical Flood story I
mean if you're going to deal with the
world's flood stories you can't really
ignore that one can you and I'm
certainly again not the first person to
wrestle with this and I'm not going to
be the last but I do think if there's
some ideas that really don't hold up to
scrutiny at all notice the the source
the prestigious journal that this the
article is taken out of a decade ago the
claim was made that Noah's Ark had been
found on Mars in the world weekly news
and I want to walk you through this
example for the simple reason that
sometimes even if you take somebody's
argument at face value you can use their
own logic to destroy their argument and
this happens to be one of those examples
so how is that well ok you notice the
picture of the Ark here that's not
actually the picture that they claimed
came from Mars that's an artist's
rendition obviously this though look
actual photo of Martian Mountain Pete
okay so this is the the photo of the
outcrop right here that is said to look
like this arc now how did they actually
get this amazing photograph of Noah's
Ark on Mars well they got it with a
satellite that was basically shown over
here now yet where I'm going with this
the what's the problem here you've got a
satellite image what is satellites do
they look down right okay notice the
respective on their actual photo of the
Martian peak it's looking up so if this
is an actual photo it was taken the
moment before that satellite crashed and
I'm not aware of NASA having that kind
of an accident with a satellite that was
looking for Noah's Ark but in any case
this is sort of a nice example of how
you can take essentially an argument
that someone would make and follow it
through to its logical conclusion and it
just pardon the pun doesn't hold water
well so what about other ideas about the
possible origin of the story of Noah's
Flood I actually think that there's two
possible the sets of events that may be
recorded in the Biblical Flood story the
first was really proposed by a guy named
George Smith who in 1872 translated the
an Assyrian flood story that bore a
striking resemblance to the biblical
flood story Smith's story is backstory
is that he grew up in the early 19th
century in England it was fascinated by
discoveries in the Middle East the
cuneiform writing and he actually taught
himself how to read cuneiform writing
the sort of the indentations that were
made with a stylus onto wet clay and
then baked into what became these these
tablets that recorded a lot of economic
data as it turned out and then also
great stories from from the region and
Smith got hired by the British Museum
after the calamity happened where
archaeologists had been excavating that
I have to go back and read my own book I
forget where they're at who Nineveh I
believe it was and they had essentially
hacked a whole bunch of these clay
tablets that they had found and put them
into crates shipped them back to the
British Museum but they didn't pack them
very well and so when they got back to
the British Museum what they had thought
were all these sort of clay tablets this
sort of like odd pottery that they had
discovered turned out have been
fragmented into tiny bits and then they
realized that all the indentations on it
was actually writing and what they had
basically done is shipped a whole
library home to England and destroyed it
in progress in transit so they
essentially ended up with the world's
greatest jigsaw puzzle with the world's
oldest books Smith basically got hired
to find comb through these little pieces
and trying
put these books back together to try and
figure out what they said and he spent a
decade toiling in the basement of the
British Museum trying to figure these
things out and then he finds this piece
here which basically tells the story
when he translated it of a righteous man
who is who was warned by a God of an
impending flood and told to take his his
livestock and his family put them on a
boat they did so they rode out through
seven days and nights of rainfall
crashed onto a mountain peak after
releasing three birds that went out to
go look for dry land and then there was
a rainbow and they built a fire and made
made an offering that's the story of
Noah's Flood it's it's the Biblical
Flood story but it predates the Bible
substantially and this made big
headlines in England back in the 1870s
when it was discovered that the Prime
Minister of England shared the stage
with Smith when he was essentially
announced his discovery of essentially
an idea of the story of Noah's Flood and
so what is it about this area in this
region that may blend itself to a
geological basis for the story of Noah's
Flood well as anyone been to New Orleans
before Hurricane Katrina and sort of
gone to the convention center and look
at the sign that's about you know four
or five feet over your head that says
sea-level this is a fairly disturbing
thing for a geologist to see and stand
below and it turns out that in big river
deltas you'll often find that the high
ground is right along the river and the
levees of the river and land slopes off
to the sides why well when it floods the
coarse sand settles out right by the
river and it builds the high ground like
the French quarters on the far areas
though when the river overtops its banks
as big rivers eventually do in a big
enough rain somewhere upstream basically
the surrounding train feels like a
bathtub well the Delta of the Tigers
from Euphrates rivers was very similar
and there were very large prehistoric
floods in the region it's possible that
one of those actually flooding the
valley wall to the wall at a depth that
you couldn't sort of stand in and
survive would have been the origin of
the story of Noah's Flood I mean I can't
tell you that it's not I can't on the
other hand tell you that it was but I
think it's a potential candidate it's a
geologically plausible argument for what
could cause a big flood in the region
where the story can actually be traced
back to its ancient Sumerian roots well
the other possible I think geological
explanation for the story of Noah's
Flood
proposal that was put forward by a pair
of oceanographers Brian Pittman than
their Black Sea hypothesis and it's
basically rooted in the idea that as at
the end of the last glacial period as
ice melted off the poles and sea level
rose there was a last gasp of meltwater
coming off of North America that raise
sea level just enough to spilled to
decant the Mediterranean into the Black
Sea
almost 8,000 years ago and what happened
what happens when you basically connect
a large body water at a higher elevation
to a smaller body of water at a lower
elevation where well the lower one fills
up to the level of the higher one and
you'll notice in the both imagery of the
black sea here I think here's the the
Bosphorus where the Mediterranean is
thought to have spilled into the Black
Sea notice all this sort of flat land
essentially on the margins Ryan and
Pitman basically suggested in a book I
think called the Noah's Flood a decade
or two ago they argued that this event
filling up the valley the Black Sea very
rapidly probably drowned some of the
world's earliest farming communities and
that the the story of that traumatic
event may have been preserved in the
story in stories of great floods for
people's that sort of fled in different
directions including the ancestors the
ancient Sumerians who brought the flood
the story of the Great Flood - - ancient
Sumeria where it then became the story
that Smith then discovered later and I'm
not going to argue to which of these two
events may is more likely to be the
origin of the story of Noah's Flood
frankly I think you can make a good case
either way but what I was really
intrigued by when I was doing the
research for this book was it was not so
much those ideas because I was vaguely
familiar with both of them but what I
was really intrigued with was how well
scientists immediately started arguing
about well did the Black Sea flood
happen how when did it happen how many
times did it happened how much did it
fill up when and we were still arguing
about elements of that I believe
creationists we're really starting to
argue about
we're immediately outraged that here was
some scientists claiming to have found
geological evidence that might be
interpreted as supporting a biblical
story and they're actually outraged and
that intrigued me because I didn't
really understand why that would be I
thought they might like be really happy
with this for some and it turns out that
the more I started getting into it the
more I sort of realized
well Ryan Pittman had discovered the
wrong flood they had discovered a flood
that only involved a small area not
covering the whole world and that
there's a sub subset of Christianity
that believes that Noah's Flood that
still believes that Noah's Flood
actually covered the entire world and so
these guys had discovered evidence for
the wrong flood so they must be wrong
and therefore they should be outraged
this set me off
on a path of trying to actually try and
understand the history of thinking about
what you might call natural philosophy
or natural theology in Christianity to
try and understand well where did this
sort of level of outrage that that was
blowback that Ryan and Pitman received
where did it actually come from what
were the roots of it and so I started
looking into early early Christian
natural theology and ran across works
like those by origin who in the second
century AD in writing about the the
first chapter of Genesis wrote that now
what man of intelligence will believe
that the 1st and the 2nd and 3rd day in
the evening in the morning existed
without Sun and Moon and stars I do not
think anyone will doubt that these are
figurative expressions which indicated
certain mysteries through a semblance of
history and not through actual events in
other words there's been a long-running
conversation and argument within
Christianity dating back to the very
earliest days of Christianity about how
to interpret the stories that are in the
Bible that relate to things that
geologists now study like the origin and
age of the world and and things like
really big floods in the shaping of
topography now with my background I was
not fully versed in that not aware of it
and I was very intrigued by this
long-running sort of argument and
between the engagement and relationship
between faith and reason st. Augustine
in the 4th century AD we also weighed in
on things like this and when he wrote
that let no one think that because the
psalmist says he established the earth
above the water we must use this
testimony of Holy Scripture against
these people who engage in learned
discussions ignorant of ignorant of the
sense of these words they will more
readily scorn our sacred books than
disavow the knowledge they have acquired
by unassailable arguments or proved by
the evidence of experience Augustine was
arguing quite explicitly against
Christians adopting views of the natural
world that could be contradicted by
direct observations of the natural world
because he then believed that would make
it very difficult to sell other people
on the religion itself and he then he
also though believe that Noah's Flood
was a global global flood but he
believed this based on the application
of Reason through what he saw in the
rocks why well what he basically saw
were seashells in rocks on mountaintops
and if you have marine organisms
embedded in the very structure of the
world at the highest elevations in your
landscape and he was in northern Africa
where this is essentially the case you
can interpret that one of two ways
either the sea used to cover the peaks
and that's and then there was water up
above there and that's how the marine
organisms got there or the mountains
rose from beneath the sea to where they
are today and in his day the latter was
the moat the more outrageous thing to
assume st. Thomas Aquinas again the 13th
century also accepted the reality of a
global flood pretty much for the same
reasons you could see fossil marine
organisms in the rocks on mountaintops
but he explicitly argued for
understanding nature what he called
God's other book on seeking to
understand both Scripture and the world
around us his basic argument was that
since in his view God wrote the Bible
and created nature those to rent areas
in which you could investigate and think
about the nature of truth had to tell
the same story because they shared the
same author and in other words if you
learned something about the nature of
the world you should have enough faith
in nature and in God's creation of
nature to essentially think about
reinterpreting any elements of the Bible
that were in conflict with that because
in the end the two could not be in
conflict we all sort of know the story
of how Galileo was subject to house
arrest for doing you know outrageously
naughty things like training a telescope
at the heavens but I got very interested
in sort of how he was his motivations
and he was not really trying to attack
the Catholic Church in with his
investigations obviously and one of my
favorite quotes from him about this time
was I did not feel obliged to believe
that the same God who is endowed as the
senses reason and intellect has intended
us to forego their use this is a quote
that I think is as pertinent in modern
politics as it is in Galileo's day but
in terms of Galileo's direct connection
to the Catholic Church he wrote in a
letter to the Grand Duchess
Christina and trying to explain his
views and why he was not really attacked
he's not really trying to set up his
ideas in conflict to the church he wrote
that if anyone shall set the the
authority of Holy Writ against clear and
manifest reason he who does this knows
not what he has undertaken free opposes
to the truth not the meaning of the
Bible which is beyond his comprehension
but rather his own interpretation now
what is in the Bible but what he has
found in himself and imagines to be
there in other words he was basically
arguing that if we discover things as
rational beings about the nature of this
world the process that we now know as
science if that stands in conflict with
what one interprets in a book like the
Bible then maybe it's the interpretation
that ought to be you know closely
re-examined as the first step well let
me return back to Jew morphology because
that was the digression there through a
micro history of theology was one I
really had to go through myself in terms
of trying to understand the nature of
how people have looked at flood stories
through time and it was fascinating but
took me more time than I thought it
would to write this book because the
story was a lot more interesting in
terms of the cross-pollination between
science and religion but so back in the
18th century 17th century the theories
for typography were essentially the
three that are shown up there on the
board thinking about how landscapes were
shaped landscapes were shaped either on
the third day of creation they were made
the way that we see them today back when
they are made in others they haven't
changed much which means the job for
geomorphologist would be really easy we
just do a one-off that's the way it was
we're done right secondly the topography
was carved by Noah's Flood essentially
that the world's topography was a direct
consequence of humaneness behavior and
sin and that topography was the world we
know today and walk around on is the
chaotic aftermath of the flood on the
idea that all the world's sedimentary
rocks and the fossils that are contained
within them were laid down by the flood
was a very central argument in the 17th
century and finally there has been
enough earthquakes in those days to
essentially acknowledge that they played
a minor role in shaping the land surface
but those first two were really the sort
of the theoretical framing devices the
theories if you will which 19th century
natural full 17th century excuse me
natural philosophers essentially framed
their view
geology and it turns out that the first
person who really put together a very
comprehensive sort of theory of the
world I'm called it a sacred theory of
the earth was was not a natural
philosopher at all he was he was a
theologian as a Cambridge theologian
Thomas Burnett who wrestled with the
problem that was very seen very much as
a current one in those days that there
wasn't enough water on earth to explain
Noah's Flood people had done they had
sort of added up how much water was in
the clouds Adams water was sort of
circulating in the on the surface of the
earth and was very you couldn't
essentially cover the world's highest
peaks with the water that was there and
so people Burnett came up with what was
actually a very clever solution to the
problem he basically argued that the
world when it was created was
essentially an oblate spheroid an egg
like thing we'll just call it a sphere
that was basically had three different
layers in it and that the outer layer
was a layer of rocks and stones that
formed the surface that we walk around
on there was an inner layer that was an
interior ocean and there was a very
metal rich dense core and this three
layer configuration allowed him to
propose a very clever idea for how
Noah's Flood could have occurred when
you couldn't find enough water on the
surface of the earth today to explain it
and what he basically said is that when
God created the world and started the
Sun started to then heat up the outer
crust of the world which started to
fracture and crack and right at the peak
of human wickedness the shell of the
earth collapsed into that interior ocean
generating Noah's Flood and then the
waters all drained back down into the
into the the rocky rubble of the mess so
they were the water was hiding somewhere
within the earth and this was actually a
very clever idea but he ran into a lot
of flack immediately first as you might
imagine if you've ever tried to ever
tried to float a gravel on a glass of
water it doesn't work very well
yeah it would be very difficult for his
exterior shell to float on top of an
interior seat from this again you can
run the experiment yourself with the
glass water so each so he originally
caught flak from natural philosophers
but he also caught a lot of flack from
theologians why well imagine the
theological problems if with the setup
for the biblical story of Noah's Flood
if God created the world pre-programmed
for destruction then God knew we were
going to fail the test of
and good or wicked and so why put us
through it all in the first place
there's certain theological problems
that come and so he got he got attacked
by both theologians and natural
philosophers and this is not one of
those cases where if you make everybody
mad you're doing the right thing it
sometimes it means you're actually just
wrong and even the founding father of
geology the person that I learned about
in my history that the what limited
history of science I was exposed to as
an undergrad or grad student he's the
person we looked to as sort of as the
founding the founding philosopher if you
will of geology because he proposed
principles founding principles that are
still used today to interpret the rock
record and he did this essentially
because he was working for the Grand
Duke of Tuscany ferdinand ii i believe
it was and he was a master he was
trained as a medical doctor and he's a
master dissection assume farmers a
farmers fishermen excuse me pulled up a
great white shark and cut off its head
and send it up to the to the grand
palace steno was the guy who got the job
of dissecting it and in the in the 17th
century a public lecture like this would
be cutting something up up here and we'd
all be sort of fascinated by the gross
miss of it all but this was essentially
so public lectures in those days he got
the job of dissecting this great shark
and what he noticed when he did that was
that the teeth of these sharks were
identical to things known as tongue
stones they were like dead ringers as
close as two eggs to one another was his
quote and when he realized and what
tongue stones were were things that
people found weathering out of rocks
they didn't know whether they were
petrified lightning strikes or what they
were steno said no these are shark's
teeth and he nailed it he basically
convinced people of that with the
treatise if he wrote on it but it
brought up this problem of well if
shark's teeth are eroding out of rocks
or in mountains how did the teeth get in
the rocks in the first place and that's
what started steno off in thinking about
his principles of geology and the ones
that he came up with we're actually
fairly simple and we still use them
today if you have a pile of sedimentary
rocks rocks that have been deposited by
stuff settling through water
well the oldest stuff is on the bottom
the youngest stuff is on the top you
know no one's going to argue that and
steno basically tried to
his principles in his words to be so
clear that nobody could really object to
them in other words if you apply them
you're the inferences you draw from them
are correct and he also his second
principle was that it that that stuff
was laid down horizontally so if you
found rocks that are tipped up on their
side they've been tipped since they were
deposited very clear very simple still
taught in introductory geology ideas
notice that with his garb here he at the
end of his life he was a Catholic bishop
that point will come back what instead
of then actually sort of do he applied
his non his principles to interpreting
the topography of the area around of
Tuscany and he came up with a six stage
model for the history of the world the
third stage of which was you guessed it
Noah's Flood
so the grandfather of geology the person
who basically laid down the founding
principles was interpreting the evidence
that he saw through applying those
principles through the theory of Noah's
Flood a theory with quotes right but the
idea that he was in he was filtering his
interpretation through that as his his
view of it now after stato basically
demonstrated that fossils were actually
real objects they weren't just things
that happened to be petrified in the in
within the world they were the remains
of real organisms that died in real
events and got buried in real rocks the
recognition that fossils were real
things was seen by many as compelling
evidence of Noah's Flood and it's you
have a lot of bones in the rocks a lot
of fossils those may be things that were
essentially drowned and this fossil over
here homo die lluvia testes that was
popularized by Jakob tortures a Swiss
naturalist in the early 18th century was
was held for as a solid evidence of
Noah's Flood in terms of being a drowned
sinner they thought it was a human
fossil it turns out it's actually a
giant salamander but this this wasn't
actually figured out for another 50 or
100 years depending on which source you
want to cite but the point is that
people started looking at and thinking
about bones they found in rocks I'm
thinking about tying them back to
organisms but and early on they were
seen as compelling proof of Noah's Flood
there were bones of mammoths that were
unearthed in upstate New York that
showed that were interpreted to show
that Adam was well over 100 feet tall
based on the verse in the Bible that
talks about there being giants in those
days and the idea that if you look at
the femur of a mammoth you know other
than its great size it kind of looks
like a human femur you know kind of the
way a giant salamander that's been
squished and buried in rock looks like a
person that's been squished and buried
in rock but if you interpret that giant
leg bone as from a human being and you
back out the scale of them they were
gigantic this all really started to
change I think when a Scottish farmer
discovered evidence for what we now call
geologic time off the coast of Scotland
this is James Hutton he was a Scottish
farmer who was very interested in
thinking about the way that the surface
of the world worked he was motivated in
part by watching sand erode off of his
fields and noticing that what was
leaving his fields was very similar to
the sand that was actually in the rocks
that he used to build the walls around
his field and he started puzzling about
sort of long periods of time and how
those kind of things could work he
basically found evidence at this outcrop
called siccar point just east of
edinburgh for earth history being much
longer and involved much deeper time
although he didn't use that phrase then
people had thought at that time when the
thing the general thinking was that the
world is a few thousand years old based
on Bishop Buster's famous accounting of
time from the Bible what is it about
this outcrop that did that we'll notice
there's these vertical rocks these grey
rocks in through here these are actually
grey they're stained red from these
upper ones but they're they're grey
they're poking through back there but
there's like sandstone this standing
vertical and then another packet of
sandstone on its side tilted and there's
a what's known as an unconformity
running through here a boundary between
these two packets of rocks now if you
take stenos principles that we just went
over a few minutes ago that sedimentary
rocks that are laid down the oldest ones
at the bottom and they're laid down flat
you can basically unpack if you will
this outcrop to realize that this is the
oldest stuff down here why wilt on the
bottom and it's standing vertical it
wasn't formed that way so you can
basically read the story of us of sand
they're made out of say if you got up
there and broke a piece off you'd see
their sandstone they're basically made
out of sand that's been lithified or
turned into rock so you can basically
know that this much
girl got laid down flat at the bottom of
an agency as sand it had to over rode it
off of some mountains or uplands
somewhere to actually get there it was
deposited there was a stack of it
deposited it got buried deep enough to
be compressed into hard rock because
this unconformity cuts in well then it
got tipped up just buried
tipped up eroded off then more sand is
deposited and again it was flat then it
gets buried deep enough to be turned
into rock then it gets tipped up and
then uplifted enough to be exposing the
coast today with this wooden realized
this meant is that this story told by
this one simple outcrop was far more
complex than could be fit into the
biblical story of an initial creation
followed by a single flood as explaining
all the world's topography and geology
why well there's two l/2 generations -
periods of deformation this outcrop
tells the story of the life and death of
two mountain ranges and that's one
catastrophe too many to fit into the
biblical narrative Hutton basically
argued this space indicated the
geological time had was essentially vast
and almost unknowable in its scope and
again again that is one of the hardest
things for for novice geologists to wrap
their mind around is the great depth of
geologic time still so by the 18th
century well in the 18th century as
scientists started to apply stenos
principles to the geology of Europe they
started to realize that there was
actually multiple periods of geologic
time they were starting to discover that
there were more periods of geologic time
than you could fit into the biblical
narrative and if you just took all the
little layers that you could trace
across great areas in Europe thought
about the time we take for that material
to settle out and then integrate it up
you're starting to get well over the
single year that's allowed in the
Biblical Flood narrative so the next
piece of the puzzle that wanted to add
was essentially involves fossils and
that's the story of georges cuvier a
french scientist who was a vertebrate
anatomist and he was the type of
scientist who does not do fieldwork
people sent him bones
he was the bone guy you found a bone
somewhere in the world you sent it to
give year and he would interpret it for
you
and he was by all accounts brilliant at
that and when Napoleon's armies sent
back samples of elephants and elephant
heads and tusks and their molars he
basically compared the the morphology of
African elephants Indian elephants and
mammoths and realized that the skulls
that we know now is mammoths that were
dug out of rocks fossil skulls bore no
resemblance to any living elephants what
Cuvier discovered in other words is he
discovered extinctions and extinctions
caused major theological problems
because what was the story of Noah's
Flood supposed to do well Noah was
supposed to save two of everything and
apparently he didn't save the mammoths
no one had ever seen a living mammoth
and everyone had always assumed that
mammoth skulls and were being unearthed
were basically you know elephant
elephants that have one stripe or
another that had died in the flood and
cooki went on to actually study the the
organisms that plants and animals in
different layers of the rock record and
managed to document that at each of
these different periods in eras of
geological time there was a different
floor on fauna and what he basically
inferred from that was that the life on
earth had been created not once but many
times and destroyed many times in other
words there was a whole series of great
catastrophes far too many catastrophes
than could be accounted for in the
biblical narrative and finally so and as
this sort of geological discoveries were
going on people the idea of which of
these great catastrophes was actually
Noah's Flood was an area of active
debate and argument in early 19th
century geology and the Reverend William
Buckland who was the first professor of
geology at Oxford originally came to
fame by claiming to have discovered
solid geological evidence for Noah's
Flood in as the most recent of qjs grant
catastrophes in this or the layer of
gravel and cave filling sediments that
could have blanketed northern Europe but
eventually when Louie Agassiz the guy
who the hall next door is named after
demonstrated that the ice ages actually
were responsible for laying down that
blanket of gravel and those odd stray
boulders that they're all over the place
in Europe it basically eliminated the
last geologic when the last traces of
geological evidence for global
flood so we can recap that the
geological hunt for Noah's Flood started
in the 17th and 18th centuries and and
as people started to apply stenos
principles to studying to studying
nature to studying Earth's autobiography
they realized that the rock record
involved more events than simply the
creation and the flood there was more to
the natural narrative than actually
gotten folded into the biblical one and
in the late 18th and 19th early 19th
centuries the flood was thought to be
recorded in the surficial deposits that
recommended just the most reason to
those catastrophes but by the 1830s or
1840 at the latest
it was pretty widely acknowledged within
the geological sciences at least that
there was no physical evidence of a
global flood by the mid 19th century it
was very well established that
geological disturbed discoveries had
essentially refuted the idea of a global
flood a book the religion of geology by
Edward Hitchcock the president of
Amherst College was both a natural
theologian and a geologist and that's to
prompt me to remind you that most of the
people we've been talking about so far
not all the but most of them that were
involved in the early study of geology
were clergy those are the people who had
the time and the expertise and the
energy and the interest to actually go
out and study how the world was put
together and to try and understand the
processes that had been used to shape
and form it
Hitchcock's summary here I think is well
worth sharing for two reasons one it's
interesting and I like 19th century
writing I'm yes I will admit it but and
but also note the date is from 1854 this
is from before Darwin's famous book
Hitchcock wrote that the history of
opinions respecting the deluge of Noah
is one of the most curious and
instructive in the annals of man almost
every geological change which the earth
has undergone from its center to its
circumference has at one time or another
been ascribed to this deluge and so
plain has this seem to those who had
only a partial view of the facts that
those who denounced as enemies of
Revelation but most of these opinions in
this dogmatism are now abandoned because
both nature and scripture are better
understood from what I can triangulate
by about the mid to late 19th century
the idea of a very young earth shaped by
no Noah's Flood had been completely
abandoned by geologists and had
pretty much abandoned by mainstream
Christian theologians who had basically
bought into the arguments that well
Augustine and Aquinas as arguments about
the the God the the gods two books being
in agreement with one another and by
that by the end of the 19th century
geologists well by the mid to late 19th
century geologists had really moved on
from the idea of studying Noah's Flood
there were arguments about was it a
regional flood nichette Caspian Sea
Charles Lyell guy who wrote a very
famous book that sort of kicked off
modern geology wrote about Noah's Flood
being from the flooding of the Caspian
Sea it's kind of right and Pitons
hypothesis one big sea over and there
were lots arguments about sort of what
may have been the other thing but the
idea of a global flood was pretty much
put to bed and geologists really started
to essentially not look at evidence for
really big floods they weren't looking
for then the idea of grand catastrophes
is things that could shape the surface
of the earth fell wildly out of favor
and the kind of Jay Harlen Bretz in the
1920s in his youth actually had the
audacity to discover evidence for those
big Missoula floods that you were
talking about a little earlier when a
glacial ice dam blocked the South Fork
of the Clark River created glacial lake
Missoula and notice this is Seattle over
here under a lot of ice in the
Pleistocene but when this ice dam failed
this lake drained out and carved the
channeled scablands of Eastern
Washington landforms that really if you
dart thinking in terms of a really big
flood are really cryptic and hard to
understand and had a scale that's really
hard to see
well Brett's figured this out on
horseback on a car in a daze before you
could actually get up in airplanes to
figure it out you can look at NASA NASA
satellite imagery today and it'd be a
lot easier to put the story together
Brett's did an incredible job of doing
the field work the old school way while
he was old school he was working the
1920s and 1930s and most of his
geological colleagues didn't believe him
for most of his career why well because
we had already put to bed the idea of
really big floods shaping topography you
know the
the war over noah's flood had been
solved in the 19th century he couldn't
possibly be discovering this kind of
stuff it took most of his career and
most of the 20th century for geologists
to actually come around and for his
views to be vindicated in terms of
looking at what shaped the topography of
Eastern Washington and the happy
resolution of this story is that he was
essentially recognized by the Geological
Society of America before he died the
downside is that wasn't until he was in
his 90s and so he didn't I think most of
the people he had fought with most of
his career had already died but so
geologists really over the course the
20th century came back to sort of
thinking about the tension between the
slow and steady processes that shape the
surface of the earth every day and these
kind of grand catastrophes that Cuvier
and and brett's were talking about and
so today now any sort of student coming
out of an undergrad or graduate program
geology is going to know he's going to
have the tools to both look for evidence
for big catastrophes and to integrate up
the day-to-day processes that say Hutton
was thinking about in terms of his deep
time we sort of look at things in
through both lenses but if we look at
the state of sort of public awareness of
geology today and we look at Gallup
polls over the last 30 years or so from
1982 up to 2012 and we look at the
proportion of the of the American public
who essentially buy into the arguments
of young Earth Creationism the world is
actually fairly young it was created in
that the shape that we know it today and
presumably that Noah's Flood played a
big hand in shaping that it's something
on the order of 40 to 45 percent of the
American public
scarily close to about half of the
American public and you'll notice that I
haven't talked about evolution at all
yet and I'm not going to why well I'm a
geologist that studies things other than
paleontology although I will show one
side in a minute that we'll get back to
that a little bit but I was very
intrigued by how so much the American
public could still believe things that
the geological foundation for had been
utterly disproved before Darwin ever got
on board the Beagle um and so I went and
visited the Creation Museum in
Petersburg Kentucky now I
I did this with a colleague and we were
it was it was very interesting it's an
incredibly well done Museum the what you
first see when you come in as you
essentially see Eve sitting here feeding
a squirrel a carrot and there's this
Jurassic Park Velociraptor hanging out
next to her very comfortably and not
going for her or the squirrel
I think he's going after vegetation
because as exhibits later there and this
thing which would tell us that that
carnivores were actually vegetarians in
the Garden of Eden you also find though
things like a triceratops with a saddle
on it
why well if as this museum argues and
that the whole history of the geological
history of the world involves the
original creation and then noah's flood
which deposited all the sedimentary
rocks that have all the world's fossils
in them then all those dinosaur bones
that we find had to been of creatures
that were living right before the flood
and therefore since there were people
before the flood the dinosaurs and
people had to live together and
presumably you know not unlike in the
famous town of bedrock where everybody
was happy and got along the things that
really surprised me much more though
were the nature of some of the exhibits
actually within it when you go into one
of the first exhibits you see reason
explicitly defined as the enemy of faith
and having been brought up in a
Presbyterian household that was taught
fairly different things I was quite
surprised by this the displays
essentially dismiss the reason as the
enemy of faith and specifically accused
scientists of a centuries-long
conspiracy to question destroyed
discredit criticized poison and replace
God's Word and each one of those
italicized words gets a whole panel
where it then goes into discussing the
argument what I couldn't get past though
is is how anyone who's ever been to sort
of a scientific meeting and sort of
noticed how viciously we attack each
other's ideas how mercilessly we rip
each other's ideas apart I mean that is
what we do as a profession the idea that
we could actually pull off a concerns
generational conspiracy to mislead the
world about the very nature of science
you know it's just beyond imagine
and yet there it is it's laid out quite
clearly I just don't understand the
mechanics of how that could work
although it may be apparently I haven't
been inducted into whatever the secret
society is that that is pulling this off
yet you also find exhibits on how Noah's
Flood deposited all the world's
sedimentary rocks and fossils no real
surprise there at this museum but the
thing that is surprising are there's
things like dinosaur footprints in
sedimentary rocks fossilized footprints
sort of what we call trace fossils and
if you think about sort of that how the
mechanics of that would work how do you
actually form a footprint in a layer of
sediment that's being deposited beneath
or by a chaotic globe destroying flood
that literally ripped up the surface of
the earth reshaped and redeposit
everything everywhere else
you really had dinosaurs walking around
on the bottom of the sea during that air
breathing dinosaurs that's what would be
required to explain those rocks in those
kind of exhibits and never mind what it
would take to explain how you would
preserve a pair of mating Turtles so
this brought me I had listed some 100
150 pages worth of in the book the rocks
don't lie of detailed reputations of
specific geological arguments that young
earth creationists have made and they've
got taken out in the interest of
readability on which anyone who reads it
should thank me for but that I was
encouraged to think about sort of one of
the sort of top three reasons for why
the sort of the fatal flaws of flood
geology or the idea that Noah's Flood
really is responsible for the geological
record that we have of life on earth and
the first fatal flaw is the one that
Thomas Burnet was wrestling with there's
not enough water on earth to actually
cover to cover the Himalaya the best
graphics of it though were in the movie
2012 that was not really the best
disaster movie ever as it says but
there's really is a fundamental problem
in terms of where all that water came
from her went the other very fundamental
problem that don't have listed up here
but it's one of my favorites is Leonardo
da Vinci's argument about why Noah's
Flood did not shape the world's geology
and lay down fossils and he had the very
simple argument that well if
was a global flood and it covered the
world you would have had a sphere sphere
oil spheroid Alysha
surrounded by a sphere of water and what
would happen there'd be no effect of
slope to that water there'd be nothing
to drive the flow it would be still
water that wouldn't actually rip up
anything wouldn't redeposit anything it
wouldn't do any actual work if you had a
global covering flood that actually
covered the highest peaks the second
fatal flaw of flood geology is the
problem that was wrestled with and
recognized in the 18th century and
that's that the geological record
involves a lot more than a single
chaotic globe wrecking flood and if you
just look at the color coding there on
the geology of the Grand Canyon the fact
that there's three different colors
there's two unconformity x' you have
this this the basement rocks down here
which a creationist would argue might
date from the original creation then you
have a layer of sedimentary rocks and
unconformity up here and then more
layered sedimentary rocks even in their
worldview you'd have to have two floods
not one to explain this stack of rocks
and we won't even argue about
radiometric dating and all the other
reasons why you can basically dismiss
their argument here but their own logic
does it for us and finally what I think
is the perhaps the most troubling
problem with note with the with the
young earth creationist view of Noah's
Flood are that 99% of all fossils are
from extinct species and I have yet to
hear a fairly coherent response to this
problem from those who claim that all
the world's fossils are a result of
Noah's Flood because what this means of
course is that either Noah did an
absolutely terrible job at trying to get
two of everything onto the ark and he
got like one he got the one-percenters
and that's it maybe there was a
subscription or something I don't know
how that worked
but either that either he did a poor job
of trying to actually fulfill his
primary duty or there's something fishy
with story you know you that's your
choice so what does it actually led to
the modern revival of young earth
creationist I mentioned mentioned a
little earlier that as far as I can tell
the idea of a young earth shaped by
global flood was pretty much out of
mainstream Christian
and II at the end of the 19th century if
you go back and read some of the work
other works by some of the people who
signed the fundamentals that started off
fundamentalism they were old earth
creationists they were not people who
believed in the in a young earth and
Noah's Flood shaping the landscape these
views really got revived in great part
due to this book the Genesis flood that
was published in 1961 it really launched
I think the young earth creationist
revival and was by an Old Testament
scholar John Whitcomb and a hydraulic
engineer Henry Morris who collaborated
on this book and they were very clear
that what they did is they basically
took the biblical story as truth and
then went to look for evidence to
support their interpretation of that
story and they advocated letting the
Bible speak for itself and then trying
to understand the geological data in
light of its teachings in other words in
modern in sort of scientific parlance
that's sort of known as you know
assuming the conclusion but they
actually I actually put off reading
their book to fairly late in the
research process for this and that was a
mistake I had fought that they basically
would be far less rational than they
turned out to be these guys actually
laid out a really good and devastating
critique of geology in the 1950s these
guys knew what they were talking about
in terms of critiquing the way
geologists were not able to explain many
of the things the basic features of the
surface of the earth they at what they
asked killed off the dinosaurs how did
great stacks of sedimentary rock end up
stranded high on continents above sea
level
how could mountains rise this is back to
the question that Augustine is grappling
with and why he thought Noah's Flood was
a global flood he'd have a good model
for how mountains could rise how did
fossils of tropical Florida end up in
rocks at the poles these are all
questions that geologists in the
theories that had been offered up to
that point we're starting to had
essentially collapsed and there were no
really good answers for him and these
guys were clever enough to figure that
out pointed out frame their book and
then say ah we know the answer there was
a global flood that resurfaced the world
and deposited all the sedimentary rocks
and fossils in other words they dusted
off Thomas Burnitz long discredited 17th
century model what did they miss well
note the date on their book 1961
Whitcomb and Morris pretty much missed
and unplayed tectonics why well plate
tectonics wasn't really accepted at the
time it was barely even proposed pieces
of it we're starting to fall into place
in their day and plate tectonics is a
good example of one of those ideas that
comes together from different
observations that then go put together
to make a theory that actually answers
questions that the developers of the
theory never thought to posed and in my
view that's actually a characteristic of
a really good theory if you put
something together based on evidence you
make a prediction and then someone
else's hey that also explains this that
and the other thing and pieces start
falling into place that's the hallmark
of a good theory the hallmark of a bad
theory is essentially if you have to
keep invoking miracles to explain away
the observations that don't coincide
with your theory and this is the problem
that Whitcomb and Morris ran into so
they basically missed out on the plate
tectonics revolution and haven't really
looked back terribly since then and
young earth creationists have been
engaged in sort of selectively using and
interpreting geological data ever since
but one of the more constructive things
that I learned in doing the research for
this book in it and sticking sort of a
couple toes in the water of theology was
that the history of the philosophy and
engagement between science and religion
is far richer and more nuanced than we
sort of tend to see today in the modern
media of sort of pitting you know Bill
Nye versus Ken Ham and those those kinds
of pseudo debates there's an awful lot
of thinking in history and people who've
wrestled with the real questions about
well how do you think about how to read
stories in the Bible when confronted
with this changing nature of geological
science it keeps discovering things
about the world and there's there's a
it's a much richer and more engaging
story than I think we tend to think
about and frankly I think that there'd
be a lot more be a lot more constructive
for more people to engage on the real
arguments that could be had rather than
the ones that were sort of thrashed out
200 years ago and settled to all
reasonable people at the time so what do
I essentially come to myself and looking
at this and thinking about well I've
come to the conclusion that the
so-called war between science
religion really ought to be viewed as a
conflict within religion over how to
view science it's about essentially how
to grapple with how how religions can
grapple with discoveries about the
material world science can go on
I sort of doing its own thing quite
happily without any particular religion
or indeed any religion at all being
being true but I think it's all
religions really need to grapple with
honestly grapple with the things that
scientists can discover about the nature
of the material world and the
conversation that we're having
essentially in the public today really
is not doing that at a level that I
think that the history of it sort of
deserves and I think that modern young
earth creationists and I want to modify
that with young earth creationist
abandoned faith that we went and what we
can learn from the study of nature in
other words they've sort of turned their
back on what we can learn from God's
other book and selectively
cherry-picking data to support a case
does not honor the data so where does
this all leave us why is this important
well I would argue to you that this
century that we're at now the 21st
century is incredibly pivotal point in
the history of humanity we have some
really big problems confronting us about
the nature of the world our place in it
our stewardship of the planet we're
facing crises in water soil energy the
atmosphere in terms of climate all which
may come to a head later this century
and frankly I think it's actually really
counterproductive as a species for us to
spend a lot of time debating arguments
that were essentially settled a couple
hundred years ago
what does this mean essentially in my
view for the the nature and the power of
the story of Noah's Flood oh I think it
is a very powerful story I think it's a
very intriguing story I think it may
very well have its roots in real events
but I think that the modern sort of
value of the story may lie much more in
its nature as a as a teaching device
about the the responsibility that
humanity has to care for creation and
actually carry forward all that is with
us on this planet into the foreseeable
future through the kinds of crises that
we actually face in the coming decades
and I think if we view the story of
Noah's Flood through that lens it's
actually still reads as a very powerful
very powerful
and very spiritual story in terms of the
nature of humanity and our relationship
to the world now people have always
essentially used the filter of faith in
the lens of reason to try and make sense
of our place in the world but I think
that the story of Noah's Flood is a very
interesting historical example of how we
can think through that and how we can
look at the way that religious stories
have actually helped shape the evolution
and development of science and how
theology has actually responded involved
in response to that to those kinds of
discoveries and I'll leave the story of
Noah's Flood there with you obviously
recommend the book the rocks do you
don't write a book if you don't want
people to read it so I obviously
recommend that everybody reads it it's
intended to make you you know think for
yourself argue with it if you want the
important parts to think about it and to
think for yourself the previous books
have written our dirt the erosion of
civilizations about the history of
farming and king of fish the
thousand-year run of salmon about the
history of salmon management in England
New England and the northwest where I
live their stories about how people
interact with nature and our economic
systems and can interact and with
natural systems in ways that don't
always lead to outcomes we desire and
the most recent one it's coming out in
November called the hidden half of
nature the microbial roots of life and
health that my I wrote with my wife
she's a biologist and we've become
utterly fascinated with the way that the
recent discoveries in the last decade or
two and it seems now every week in
science and nature are revealing new
ways that microbial life is influencing
the macroscopic life that we know and
how foundational that is to the practice
of Agriculture and medicine and how
wrong we've gotten some elements of that
because we have not fully appreciated
the role microbial life plays so thank
you very much for the invitation I look
forward to chatting with anybody at the
reception afterwards
money